going for an Indian or having a curry is
almost a stereotypically British as
roast dinners or fish and chips
there are around 12,000 curry houses in
Britain the word came from the Tamil
Carrie which meant a spiced sauce but
gradually the term was adapted and used
as a generic term for any stool I trade
from the Indian subcontinent rather
ignoring such subtleties as regional
differences in completely different
flavors textures cooking methods and
ingredients the first step in up mention
of Korean English is 1598
but the first recipe for curry published
in Britain wasn't until 1747 by which
time Brits long time traders with India
was slowly taking over the country
thousands of British men and women spent
time in India they had Indian cooks and
servants and while some tried to
maintain Western eating habits most
quickly embraced the taste of their new
home when they returned to Britain they
brought their new love of Indian food
back with them those who had lived in
India knew very well that not all Indian
dishes were curry and when the first
auto Piet's short lived Indian
restaurant in Britain opened in London
in 1810 its menu contained Kitsch tree
chutney and pulao dishes later named by
the anglicized names kedgeree chutney
and pilla manuscript book is kept by
those in the know also differentiated
between dishes but they were very much a
minority and in Britain curry became a
catch-all term for almost anything with
Indian spices slowly certain and dishes
especially chicken curry which used an
elderly fowl which had stopped laying
eggs entered the mainstream repertoire
ready-made curry powders were widely
sold British palates were not used to
Indian spices and the early recipes are
more like gently flavored methi stews
and they even with turmeric ginger and
galangal
with cayenne for a hit by the 19th
century curry was in every cookbook
mainly as a leftover dish the Anglo
Indian cuisine of this era was a hybrid
using pickled cucumbers to replace mango
apple instead of tamarind and ready-made
spice blends galore it was great but had
very little in common with its Eastern
roots Queen Victoria took a different
approach regularly eating Indian dishes
prepared by the cook to her Indian
attendants who joined the royal staff at
her Golden Jubilee in 1887 the were a
few eating house is run by Indians
mainly for other Indians in port towns
but it took until the 1920s for
high-profile restaurants to open
catering for a British market by 1946
the
around 20 Indian restaurants in London
boom time for curry came out for the
second world war when the partition of
India brought migrants from Punjab and
slits Britain in the 1970s civil war in
Bangladesh saw many Bangladeshis flee to
Britain and even today many apparently
generic Indian restaurants are really
Bangladeshi curry in its 1970s form was
cheap and cheerful adapted for British
tastes in 2001 the then foreign
secretary Robin cooked declared boldly
that Britain's national dish was chicken
tikka masala a classic example of an
Indian dish buttered chicken meeting
British tastes in this case with the
addition of cream and allegedly cream of
tomato soup in the last decade or so the
British relationship to Indian food has
changed most of us have grown out of
wanting something so hot it'll
hospitalizes leading Indian chefs are
teaching us that there is so much more
to Indian food than the comforting
predictability of the average restaurant
menu maybe after two hundred and fifty
years we simply come full circle